we've uncovered a number of secretive
government units that claim to be
fighting misinformation and
disinformation actually they're
monitoring and recording people that are
criticizing the government and
government policies the 77th Brigade had
these kind of conspiracy theories around
it like are they watching us online
controlling what we say I don't think
anyone really took it seriously we
weren't even actually looking into the
unit until a whistleblower came forward
to us what The Whistleblower told us is
that there were absolutely no safeguards
or controls in place whatsoever to
prevent this monitoring affecting people
in Britain and that and that it was
affecting people in Britain they were
doing General searches on social media
in English language on topics that
Johnson government was interested in we
were being surveilled by our own
military we are in the process of
winning a campaign against GPS ankle
tags for
um innocent campaigners you know people
that haven't even broken the law if
they're deemed disruptive you could be
fitted with a GPS ankle tag to monitor
where you go and make sure that you
don't go welcome the law and they're
going to track your movements yes it's
even the Russians or the Chinese I said
we're going to ankle tag our protesters
you'd be like wow they've really gone
for it now you know like this is really
extreme and this is happening in in
Britain
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitten
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is a
friend of the show who brings us
troubling news she's the director of Big
Brother watch here in the UK which has
just produced this report Ministry of
Truth which talks quite a bit about the
government surveillance of people who
have wrong opinions silky color welcome
back thank you very much for having me
uh so everyone can go back and watch our
first interview if you they want to
backstory or new or whatever but you're
the director of Big Brother watch which
is a civil liberties organization here
in the UK you've just released a report
uh that is really really worrying tell
us about it yeah so we've uncovered a
number of secretive government units
that claim to be fighting misinformation
and disinformation
and
um they've been very resistant to
transparency so over a long time we've
been investigating them and we found
that actually they're monitoring and
recording people that are criticizing
the government and government policies
and we found that this was particularly
active during the pandemic but that we
think that they're active on other
topics and it's particularly affecting
members of parliament uh journalists
academics experts and campaigners
um so you know not the kind of Boogeyman
Russian disinformation bot Farms or
whatever it is that the government would
have us believe that these units are
working on you're off the hook mate no
well probably not actually I mean one of
the things you mentioned to us is we
could we could see if we are included in
that I imagine we would be actually
given that the people that you were
talking about quite a lot of them we've
had on the show you know Toby Young
Julie Hartley Brewer and others right
yeah um they're people who have big
followings on social media in particular
that's what the government seem to be
interested in they're also interested in
alternative platforms so for example one
of the documents we have describes
parlor as a threat and that was when it
had just launched and the government
were interested in senior politicians
who had gone on to that platform and
they're you know recording the fact
they've gone onto that platform
um so yeah when they are collecting
um posts that people have put online
they're also looking at engagement so
that's why you know a show like this and
people like your guests are quite likely
to be
um you know in the crosshairs really
because they're looking at people who
are talking about controversial topics
and looking at then the engagement rates
so they're literally recording numbers
of retweets and this sort of thing and
what are they doing with this
information because one of the things
that people might say is well the guy I
mean anyone can monitor anything you
know what's what's wrong with noticing
who's tweeted what and how many likes
they got um
censorship and propaganda
um the units in question claim to work
with the tech companies to flag things
that might breach their terms of service
or that are inappropriate and we've even
had ministers say this in the House of
Commons but the problem is that people
have just assumed that it's all this
nasty stuff that in question and so
everyone's kind of congratulated it now
we know it's basically dissent
um so taking stuff down or pressuring
social media companies to take stuff
down and the other part of it is I think
understanding the public conversation so
that the government can respond and that
could be through
um trying to work with their SEO to get
their search results up higher in search
engines on key topics especially around
the pandemic or issuing rebuttals to
newspapers or social media users
um basically to amplify their point of
view in response and I mean that's the
element of it that you can say is
reasonable whether it's proportionate to
be keeping records and tabs on
dissidents I would say is probably not
but the element of this kind of
collusion of state and big tech power
to silence people for lawful opinions
should really make everyone shudder
um completely agree with you and how
long has this been going on for silky
um all of the units but one that we've
identified were started during the
conservative government but most of them
have been in really recent years since
around 2018 but the pandemic was
absolutely Catalyst for it really taking
off so the central unit that is
responsible for most of this is the
counter disinformation unit that's what
it's called although we haven't seen
much of them uh them doing much around
disinformation
um it sits within the department for
digital culture media and Sport
um so it's like a policy unit you know
they're they're not Spooks
um but they're acting in that way
um they had started this unit actually
um
in 2019 I think it was during elections
and then it was stood down and then
during the pandemic it was stood up
again and now it's permanent
um and it's folding in other kind of
disinformation Specialists from across
government to feed into this central
unit
the other thing that happens you know
and I think important to bear in mind
that the pandemic was
you know it was the blank check for a
massive extension of powers across the
peace really in government and so
the birth of some of the activity
um that we saw during the pandemic was
actually in this secretive
army unit called the 77th Brigade The
77th Brigade had these kind of
conspiracy theories around it like are
they watching us online controlling what
we say and I don't think anyone really
took it seriously we weren't even
actually looking into the unit
until a whistleblower came forward to us
and told us what was really going on
during the pandemic within that unit
um the public statements from the Army
were that the 77th Brigade were sort of
stood up during you know the beginning
in March 2020
um and that they were dealing with
foreign disinformation and in response
to questions about would you ever do
anything domestically of course not all
of our operations are directed overseas
um what the Whistleblower told us is
that there were absolutely no safeguards
or controls in place whatsoever to
prevent this monitoring affecting people
in Britain
um and that and that it was affecting
people in Britain they were doing
General searches on social media in
English language
um on topics that Johnson government was
interested in
um so you know basically trying to gauge
public opinions see what people were
thinking about different elements of
covid and the policies uh and then they
were collating these reports including
of individuals we saw even a university
student you know someone that doesn't
have a big following they're just
collating these records of uh what
people were saying and thinking and then
sending those up to central government
silky why did it explode over the
pandemic was it because more and more
people were online so there was an
opportunity to do that this was going to
be the moment was it because they were
genuinely worried about misinformation
being spread during the pandemic and as
a result people potentially dying
I think all of these things can be true
at the same time
um of course people were worried about
public health obviously during the
pandemic of course people were
um but you know does recording what
university student is worried about
um you know about the virus that's not
saving lives is it you know I think
actually one an interesting thing that
The Whistleblower said was that
um there had been a desire for the Army
to demonstrate this information Ops
capability
um and the 77th Brigade describes itself
as involved in non-lethal engagement for
Modern Warfare against adversaries
um and so you know you think of these
kind of sophisticated overseas
operations but they were interested in
demonstrating to government that we can
do these kind of elite information Ops
and so it was an attractive thing to say
we can deal with the dangerous
misinformation and disinformation which
I think we now have to be honest and
especially in light of our report there
is a moral Panic about it and it's
overblown and now we need to have a
sober conversation about what we really
mean when we're talking about
misinformation and disinformation
because what the Army got away with in
this instance was an accumulation of
resources to do basically nothing
nothing worthwhile but that does have a
serious impact on Brits and meant that
we were being surveilled by our own
military you know with military power
it's extraordinary really
um and so I think that so there's a few
things that and this happened after 9 11
as well didn't it you know the desire
for certain elements within the
military-industrial complex and business
and government to show that they can uh
with the with more resources they can
provide these new services and do these
new things with civil liberties put
ready to the side
um
so that was going on and of course I
think the overriding thing the
fundamental thing that I hope we're now
thinking about more clearly is that
governments will always try to
accumulate power and having power over
information is the most extraordinary
power you can have if you can can
strongly influence and even control what
people are able to say to each other
what people are able to see and hear and
read
um especially when it comes to criticism
of of your own policies you know for a
government really for an authoritarian
government that's the dream and that's
really the territory that we're now on
the precipice of and the disturbing
thing is that so many people
in the liberal establishment
um are actually
calling for this they want the
misinformation units to do more be more
active be more present and to scrub the
internet of wrong ideas and if people
think you're exaggerating I had a
fascinating experience being on question
time last week because they have this
question that they do before that isn't
broadcast and it was about whether
Donald Trump should have been allowed
back on Facebook and Instagram and
foreign I don't have the words to
describe to you how people think I think
some people have got themselves into a
position where they don't they've
forgotten that old uh there's no
Solutions only trade-offs thing and they
don't think that there are trade-offs to
pursuing maximum safety online and so
there was this the labor woman next to
me for example she was like I think this
country should be leading the world in
what we control people in terms of
people saying online
and because it wasn't on camera I didn't
say anything but it's like do we want to
compete with China and North Korea is
that is that what and a lot of people in
that audience as well that that's how
people think now safety I want safety
and they think that safety doesn't have
a cost how do we how do we communicate
about this it's
it's actually terrifying and it's
terrifying it's happened so quickly
um both that people have become
complacent about their Liberty in that
way you know when you're saying that you
want to shut someone else up for lawful
speech I'm not talking about Trump in
particular but this whole kind of
culture that you're referring to you're
also saying you're happy to be shut up
for things that you might say that are
lawful and that your friends can your
communities can
um the death of speech is the death of
ideas if you have a society without
dissent and without Free Speech you're
it's a graveyard it's a graveyard of
dying ideas where we will never progress
we will never move forward and I do
think there is like a intellectual
poverty in all of this as well because
when people are resorting to silencing
others they're saying that they don't
have the capacity to reason with them
and they don't believe in the strength
of ideas and Association and debate and
discussion to reach truths you know
truths are now things that are dictated
from an elite you know back to we're
back to kind of priesthood and you've
got like the likes of Mariana spring at
the BBC the disinformation reporters and
so on who are like the priests and the
priestesses of truth it's so bizarre
um in my view but in also just the kind
of post-enlightenment view or Free
Speech you just have that the most open
Forum possible is the way that you
achieve
um rationality and truth and Discovery
and progress you're arguing but this is
kind of the point that we've come to
where I don't think people a lot of
people think about it that way at all
free speech has become a thing that
people who don't want progress
apparently use right so if you if you
say I'm pro-free speech that means you
don't want progress how's that happened
I don't know I don't know to really work
on The Branding or Free Speech because
yeah exactly free speech is is about
um it's about progress It's about
movement it's the thing that led to gay
rights to women's rights to all the
rights that we have you know are
achieved through being able to speak
truth to power
um and I think the pandemic was really
killer for this because
it was the idea was perpetuated that you
know just for now actually free speech
and these dangerous ideas can can kill
people you know and it's and we need to
save lives so shut up basically
um and that's what's reflected I think
in the work that these units were doing
these disinformation units
um blank check no oversight politicians
didn't even have curiosity about what
they were doing no one was asking the
questions and we've had to dig dig and
dig to find what I'm afraid was probably
inevitable that when you allow you know
resources to accumulate in the shadows
um then they will be serving the
interests of the powerful not of the
public that just seems obvious but
obviously you know that is what we've
now found and uh something needs to be
done about it I mean actually these
units need to be shut down you can't
have senior politicians being spied on
by their own government for wrong thing
um look I when I was reading through the
report I couldn't quite believe it but
then I thought of course I can believe
it and the particular thing that I found
very believable was the collusion
between government and big Tech because
we've seen it with the Twitter files
which Elon Musk released and
you start to really really worry where
you think like anything that I say
online could report to be reported back
and not only could it mean that somebody
could lose their job it means that the
government
is then tracking them that's like
something out of Soviet Russia yeah it
is
um and there's been quite a lot of like
pinch myself moments during this
um I think particularly when you know so
to give some examples of the people
affected uh David Davis MP who has been
a member of parliament for decades very
well-known civil libertarian a senior
within the conservative party who of
course in government an ex-minister
um and he his position during the
pandemic was he praised the vaccine
rollout he spoke a lot about vaccines
um and he but he was very critical of
mandatory domestic vaccine passports as
of course we were we did a massive
campaign on it
as you were as all the sensible people
were probably all on the list yeah yeah
and he and the fact that he did you know
is really quite extraordinary
um actually this was a mainstream
political opinion
um the Parliamentary Rebellion against
vaccine passports was the biggest
Rebellion since uh the vote on the Iraq
War in Parliament now this was a big big
deal politically
um why should he be being recorded by
disinformation units for actually giving
fact-based criticisms of vaccine
passport scheme and let's not forget who
were the purveyors of disinformation
during this period because a lot of
people were saying vaccine passports
were going to save lives they were
absolutely critical we can't go out
without them and all the rest of it we
found out in our legal challenge that we
did
um we did two against the Welsh
government and the English and the UK
government on vaccine passports that
they had no evidence that they were
going to have any measurable impact on
public health and we have that in
writing
um and yet we were told such a different
story so you know it's these kinds of
things where you think yeah this is
getting a bit
um you know what democracy is really
falling apart here another example
um it was Carl Hennigan Professor Carl
Hennigan from Oxford University Center
for evidence-based uh medicine this is
someone that surely we want to be
listening to during a pandemic
in a disinformation report he's an
expert his uh he was taken off Twitter
for a period uh his studies were marked
as false by Facebook but again by these
you know like people that could not
compete with uh Fresco Hennigan in terms
of his expertise it's absolutely absurd
and the fact that both of these people
are in these government reports
um and that we know also they were being
censored David Davis had a video taken
off YouTube
um the speech that he gave against
vaccine passports that we put on our
Channel and the brother watches channel
was taken off YouTube until we
complained and got it put back on
um we weren't able to get the
correspondence between these units and
social media companies they also won't
tell us how many times they flagged
stuff uh no information whatsoever so
something very useful that Elon Musk
could do would be disclose all of the
communications between the British
government and Twitter
um during the pandemic and let's get to
the bottom of this do you know I have a
certain sympathy I can't believe I'm
saying these words for the social media
companies when you think you I remember
at the beginning of the pandemic we had
David Ike getting millions of views for
things that were palpable nonsense
and then moving forward then you have
the government pressing down on them you
have people saying that they're
platforming misinformation weren't they
in many ways between a rock and a hard
place as well yeah they're totally not
prepared for they weren't prepared for
that kind of a challenge
um
but in my view the easiest thing for
them to do would be to follow the laws
of the country that they operate in and
then choose what countries they operate
in so you know it's not against the law
to spout nonsense and it's really easy
to deal with
um and I do worry as well that if for
example you've got people that are uh
say spreading conspiracy theories about
5G masts or this kind of thing
um if you just silence those people what
do the people who are interested in the
ideas do and where do they go and what
do they then think you had to silence it
is it that dangerous you know these
ideas so you know you'll either think
yeah it's dangerous because it's wrong
or you think it's dangerous because you
don't want me to know it for some reason
I think the best way of challenging
nonsense or falsehoods of any type and I
mean from Fringe people all the way up
to the stuff some of the stuff that gets
printed in the mainstream press is more
speech and to just suppress it and
silence it means that it will just grow
and cultivate in another part of society
or the internet
um where
um there's a probably a less rational
discussion it's okay are you concerned
that you've just uncovered a tip of the
iceberg here because I would imagine if
I was a powerful person in government
and I've identified a Toby Young or a
Julia Hartley Brewer or Professor Carl
Hennigan or a David Davis who's annoying
me and not allowing me to do the things
that I'm doing for public health quote
unquote I'd quite want to know what
they're sending to each other on their
telegram groups and their WhatsApp chats
and their text messages and what they're
saying on their voicemails and on their
phone calls is there any suggestion that
that was going on
uh we have absolutely no idea
but
um I think the fact that we are finding
such extreme activity so low down the
scale within government policy units
um makes you think well
yeah what was going on in gchq what was
going on in MI5
um
we they have extraordinary powers to do
uh exactly what you're talking about you
know to hack phones and to incept calls
and messages and all the rest of it we
spoke last time I was here about those
Powers
um at length
um and you know public health is in law
one of the reasons uh that
um
you know governments can sometimes
intrude on your privacy or intrude on
your right to freedom of expression
um but it's about proportionality and so
who knows we need probably more
whistleblowers
it's an interesting aspect of the work
of the 77th Brigade in my view and based
on some people that I've spoken to
is that
um yes it's concept really concerning
what they were doing I mean just
searching all of the internet clearly
impacting people at home clearly with
policy direction from number 10 to look
at things that number 10 is interested
in but
um it was also a bit of a distraction
and meant that people were especially
before we found out what we've just
found out some people were
um
I guess building conspiracy theories
around what the 70 Cent Brigade were
doing and the name is kind of spooky
isn't it so Brigade you know what
they're up to
um but then people weren't talking about
where the power really lies and actually
an interesting aspect of what the
Whistleblower tells us is that they had
their resources were crap they had
nothing they wouldn't have been able to
find disinformation if they'd been
desperate to because they didn't have
the resources they didn't have the
skills even
um and you know the Whistleblower
suspects that there was foreign
disinformation being spread at the time
um some of which you know other people
have written about perhaps stuff coming
from China for instance and that they
would have had absolutely no chance of
finding it so where does the power
really lie to be doing some of this
stuff and you know that would be in gchq
and MI5 and based on what we know about
their activities over the years and
their interest in
um
uh politics you know a lot of this
Rapport and why our investigation has
strong Echoes of Reds under the bed that
we saw in the 80s where
um UK intelligence agencies were really
interested in
um you know political surveillance what
union activists were up to and what
leftists were up to more broadly as you
had McCarthyism in the U.S for the same
kind of thing
um so the intelligence agencies have
formed for this and wouldn't it be the
fact that during a pandemic
um you know this kind of uh
sense of Crisis that they would be
highly active during that period if
policy units were yeah I think so silky
isn't part of the problem that we're
here talking and we're talking about the
government and I'm thinking ah there's a
general election in a couple of years
we're going to we're going to invoke
these bastards out it's going to be fine
and then I'll remember that then it's a
labor coming in and they're even more
insane about this yeah well
um
yeah the the conversation around
misinformation and disinformation I
think to some degree hasn't happened yet
and around Free Speech generally it has
been really poor
on the Online safety bill for instance
you know we've got this regulation
coming through at the moment which is
about precisely what you know the person
you were sitting next to at question
time is talking about controlling speech
on the internet lawful speech
um so and it's both Tory and labor I
mean the the Tory guy was like you know
we've been too slow to catch up with a
wave of hate online that's how they
frame it yes and and look I think we
should acknowledge that the internet and
the ability to communicate in that scale
poses new challenges there is no
question about that because I think the
example you gave me was actually a
really good one David eicher the
beginning pandemic you know if you get
to a point where somebody can go on a
YouTube show or even on a private
platform of some kind and say stuff and
then an hour later people are burning
down five gmasks I can see why our
government would feel the need to
to do something about that and you have
stories of kids who see suicide material
and end up you know like there's bad
outcomes so you can you can see what why
that would be an issue but but
it's just it seems to me that a lot of
people don't realize that there are
trade-offs here that have to be really
carefully watched and on the online
homes Bill did get watered down a little
bit didn't it yeah can I just come back
on that okay there are trade-offs on on
a lot of what happened during the
pandemic people were
made to be by the government to be
scared for their you know really really
scared yes not leaving that people still
have mental health problems from this I
I was at dinner with someone recently
who said that their wife had left their
Loft for months so you know because they
were isolating and scared to come out of
the house you know there are a lot of
people that have been badly affected by
this and look we still don't know by the
way whether lockdown saved lives or not
they may have over a period of time
ended up costing more lives than they
saved so I agree with you there's still
a big Fallout of course you've got
Sweden to look you know we just look at
Sweden on that maybe but um yeah I mean
big big questions that are still clearly
being
um answered and so you know yes of
course you know with some extreme Fringe
speech there can be things there could
be outcomes we can link to it but
actually we just lived through an
extraordinary government propaganda
period that also had terrible terrible
impacts on a lot of people whilst by the
way they were having piss-ups in 10
Downing Street you know so the behaviors
of the people that were behind this were
totally contradicting the way that other
people were made to feel
um and so trust is disintegrating
um and part you know one of the reasons
that this
matter so much and that we can't put
down all these social ills to just like
people spreading disinformation and
misinformation online someone's gone out
and attacked a 5G mask because they read
a tweet I think it's more complicated
than that I think trust and Authority is
totally disintegrating and people don't
really trust in the mainstream press in
the same way they don't trust their
governments covert didn't help did it
looking at how the government behaved
during those years so
um you know A lot's gone really wrong
and what we've exposed in this report
will confirm a lot of people's fears as
well about the kinds of excesses
um that government might seek during
this period now with extra laws coming
through
um like the Online safety Bill and also
several anti-protest laws there's just
more and more and more of it
um so the online the Online safety bill
has been watered down to some degree I
think in no small part because of big
brother watches campaign working with uh
parliamentarians and other Free Speech
groups
um so now this whole concept that was
going to be introduced into law of legal
but harmful speech which you know I it
always
um sort of gives chills really the idea
that there are things that you are
lawful to say but but you can't say that
anymore exactly
um which is yeah a legal mess
um but actually what's coming to its
place is that social media companies
terms and conditions are now a legal
Duty so they will be legally bound not
just as in a contract between
the person using it and the company but
actually with the government they are
legally bound to observe those terms and
conditions which given some of the terms
and conditions we've seen over the years
um is quite strange you know so let's
say
um if a platform says that you can't
misgender anyone
um you know looking at the case that's
being discussed at the moment of the
Scottish trans
[Music]
we haven't read loads about the case but
I'm just thinking about it okay so
Scottish trans woman who um is a
two-time racist okay right
um you know would it then would would
British law then say if a platform said
you can't misgender anyone uh would the
would then this new construction mean
that you can't use the wrong pronouns
for this person on a social media
platform
according to the government because the
government is making these terms and
conditions a legal Duty do you see what
I mean so you know when YouTube has
crazy rules or you know Twitter May less
so now I don't know but um yeah it's
strange or like you know musk not
wanting his private jets to be tracked
or whatever if that becomes Twitter law
you know that kind of becomes the law
because the government is saying it's
now a legal Duty that you always impose
these laws so that's a nonsense but
unfortunately no one's talking about it
silky do you think the only way that
people really wake up is when something
happens or an event happens that is so
powerful or It just strikes the people
as something that is completely wrong so
for instance the one time when we
actually changed football stadiums in
this country was after the Hillsborough
disaster because it was such an awful
awful event
and if you look at the pandemic the
moment people woke up when they started
to think about you know the right to
congregate and the right to protest is
the police's actions during the Sarah
everard vigil do you think we just need
something to happen like I don't know
what it is where people just
collectively come to their senses
maybe but by then it will be too late so
my message would be please don't wait
please don't be complacent
um if you can remember what that feeling
was like when we were all told by the
government to stay in your home weren't
sure if we were going to be able to
travel again didn't know when we'd be
able to be out didn't know if normal
life was coming back and of course you
know a lot of us have fought tooth and
nail to make sure that it did and that
all of these laws were repealed but
there was a sense then like is it too
late and I think a lot of people that
obviously has you know made a lot of
people a lot more alive to how precious
their Liberty is and I also think if
some if anyone hasn't kind of got it
during these couple of years then you
might never but you know please don't be
complacent and don't wait because
um yeah the the you know we can lose
these freedoms we can lose these
Liberties really really quickly but also
the culture shifting you know so already
the fact that you can sit in an audience
of people and they have these
really you know almost disdain actually
for free speech not even an indifference
to it but actually to it's been recast
as a threat to democracy rather than the
foundation of it
um then you know something's going
really really wrong how do we come back
from that and I think that's why
conversations like these and platforms
like these are important because
um this is as much about you know
culture and ideas as it is about
anything people have to really realize
now how important these these Liberties
are that's why I always say to Americans
because they're like well how come you
know like there are certain issues in
terms of the cultural stuff that we
often talk about in the show we're
actually in the UK we're doing much
better than than they are in America but
on speech we're doing far worse and they
always go well is it because of the
First Amendment and I don't think it's
because of the first amendment I think
it's because they have a culture a First
Amendment culture which is at the end of
the day like anyone can say what they
want unless they're on exciting violence
we don't have that we don't have that
and the pandemic was almost like I
almost I don't know maybe I'm wrong but
I think Francis and I were both very
disappointed in in this country actually
and in many people in this country
because maybe we were projecting our own
views and values onto it but I certainly
didn't think that the polling numbers
and people's behavior during the
pandemic showed that we live in a
society that values freedom of
expression
yeah but it's all relative I mean
how the UK did compared to the rest of
Europe you know we did a lot better than
a lot of European countries we got rid
of the restrictions quicker than anyone
else we didn't have you know the EU now
has a eu-wide super State covered pass
system uh they're introducing biometric
borders you know so you know they've got
millions of people enrolled in databases
with IDs digital IDs and passes and you
know
we're not there and I think though there
is something about
um
perhaps the parliamentary system and you
know our culture
um
but I think where the um
where the vacuum really was was in the
opposition and on the left
um it to be honest and I'm saying that
as a non-partisan you know we are
non-partisan organization I say it's
from a totally non-partisan point of
view and I should say as well for people
like you genuinely are like that's not a
thing that you say because you're a
right-wing evil bigot
you're not power to political you just
care about these issues yeah that's true
we have done yes yes exactly which makes
you right wing yeah
I'm thinking about next government and
um you know where the currents are going
on these issues
um you know yeah it is really worrying
so the things like the investigation and
and the campaign that we're running now
to shut down the ministry of truth it's
an opportunity it well it's an appeal
really we're we're trying to create
disruption in this current
um and to try to turn the tide back
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be cancel culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
so what can people do silky because this
is one of my biggest frustrations with
doing this and I'm very proud of what
we've built here but quite often we have
a conversation and look Francis made a
great Point like okay we've got general
election coming up okay the tours are
probably going to get kicked out now
what like what if I'm watching this what
what am I supposed to do how am I going
to change this
um go to minitruth.co.uk
um which is our campaign page to shut
down the ministry of Truth we've got a
petition that people can sign please
sign it sign up to our emails for
updates about the campaign because we
won't let this go
um you know all we will ask people to do
is sign a petition or join us get the
ministry of Truth t-shirt
um you know and just being be involved
in in the in the campaign
um but you know really
talk about it share the information
share this with people share information
with um you should share the information
with people
um we I think so much is happening
because
um politicians think that people just
don't care and
um particularly on Free Speech you know
these disinformation units
misinformation units have popped up
because of the moral Panic that's been
drummed up really about people saying
the wrong things online
um and I think we need to see at least a
similar Force back saying Free Speech
really matters and actually even where
you are talking about the misinformation
online the best way of dealing with it
is with more information with more
speech
um so I think there are things that
people can do definitely I mean
certainly through campaign groups like
ours and I think the benefit of us do
you know doing investigations in-house
is for precisely that reason that you
know we follow up everything with action
and we won't drop it until you know
there has been change because it's not
only online that we've seen the laws
being changed it's also the right to
protest the government have fun have
completely changed the laws can you just
explain that a little bit yes we've been
campaigning on a couple of the
anti-protest bills that have been coming
through Parliament lately because of of
course we've all seen the scenes of
people gluing themselves to rows and
throwing things on paintings and all the
rest of it but
police already have powers to deal with
those things
um but under the pretense of dealing
with these people we're just getting
more and more extreme anti-protest
Powers introduced in fact we are in the
process of winning a campaign against
GPS ankle tags that the government want
to introduce for innocent campaigners
you know people that haven't even broken
the law if they're deemed disruptive you
can be fitted with a GPS ankle tag to
monitor where you go and make sure that
you don't go home welcome the law and
they're going to track your movements
yeah
yes and monitor what you do on the
internet and uh control what you do on
the internet to make sure you're not
doing protest related activities on
there either so basically if you're if
you're an effective campaigner you will
be disruptive in some sense right
um and this word disruptive is being
used to usher in these extraordinary
curbs on your right to protest and this
really is the kind of power where I
think you know if even the Russians or
the Chinese I said we're going to ankle
tag our protesters you'd be like wow
they've really gone for it now you know
like this is really extreme and this is
happening in in Britain
I mean that is just
that's beaut that's that's beyond belief
that they're gonna ankle tag people who
they claim to be disruptive and who are
not guilty of a crime yeah it really is
but I think we're winning this campaign
I think that we I think I think that we
are the government has said that they're
going to maintain some of these Powers
but that it seems like they're uh
willing to drop the ankle tags finally
but it's not confirmed right just now
how do you think
it would just be me walking around my
flat but it's how do you and and coming
here that's about all I do nowadays but
how do you how how do they sit in
government and come up with these ideas
like have they not read or well like
does it not occur they've read Orwell
they're following the script very
closely yeah it seems like it doesn't it
yeah but just with the benefits of
Technology you know so this is like a
high-tech dystopia
um which is you know the blueprint is
China you look at how closely you can be
followed and tracked
um let alone through an ankle tag you
know things like facial recognition
surveillance which the police are using
more and more now
um but yeah I mean again and this stuff
can only happen in an environment where
people are not protecting their rights
closely enough where where people are
I've lost sight of how important it is
to be able to protest against your
government and also you know if the
other people who are in Parliament in
opposition are not speaking up loudly
enough about these things the reason
that they won't is because there is
because the Press is so anti-protest at
the moment
um and so this really safe line is being
followed of just kind of allowing
the government to self-implode
um
I am anti-extinction Rebellion gluing
themselves and blocking ambulances but
as you said there are laws in place for
the police to deal with protests that
are actually endangering lives or
damaging property and whatever and I'm
perfectly happy for those laws to be
applied but I don't want those people
ankle tagged if they haven't broken the
law yeah but quite like the existing
laws to be enforced though which we
don't do any of that on protest and
anything else by the way but instead we
just make up new laws to deal with other
things it was like the David Ames murder
last year where
the guy tragically is stabbed to death
by an islamist
and then they're all banging on about
online hate speech and you're going to
these things aren't connected but we
seem to just go you know whatever the
problem is let's take some people some
of people's rights away from them yeah
it's really lazy isn't it
um and also I think particularly around
policing we're overlooking the fact that
the police particularly in London are
totally dysfunctional you know they they
cannot they're committing more crimes
than they're solving I mean they just
cannot deal with
um you know even these most basic uh
public order issues or even serious
crime or really anything and so the
easiest thing for government to do is to
just whack through a bunch of new
extraordinary powers and then say we've
been really tough
um but the same things will happen
because where Powers already exist
they're not being used
um you know and why is that happening
why why aren't the police using the
powers they're totally dysfunctional
under resource I mean I I'm this is like
a big conundrum at the moment isn't it
how do you deal especially with the
Metropolitan Police like how is it so
fatally broken policing in London that
we have really high crime
terrible sexual violence as well
and literally thousands of police
officers under investigation as well for
for some of these crimes I mean
something really really has gone wrong
there and probably a lack of political
leadership as well and that that's been
allowed to happen and that what's being
thrown at the problem is more police
Powers now that's that that just doesn't
make sense and I fear the problem will
get worse before it gets better until
you have proper political leadership on
it
oh I was going to say there was one more
thing that the government brought in
during the pandemic that made my blood
rung cold which was they wanted to
implement some Powers against
journalists
do you remember what this was that what
actually happened with that
so much has happened I mean I know that
a lot of journalists were
arrested and manhandled by police during
this time
um and actually coming back to these
anti-protest laws one of the new
anti-protest bills that has come into
Force
um has already been used
um there was an LBC journalist that was
arrested for covering Extinction
Rebellion
um yeah for I think it was conspiracy to
cause a public nuisance
um which they were basing on the fact
that she may have known that the protest
was going to take place so now
journalists is kind of seen as like
proxy spies for the police you know
which goes to show I think the risks of
uh introducing extreme Powers you can't
just say well they probably won't be
used like with the other ones so they
will be sometimes in the worst
circumstances
um so you know these anti-freedom
laws will affect
um journalists and the whole kind of
Civil Society that's supposed to prop up
democracy
say okay thank you so much for coming on
the show have I cheered you up yes you
are massively he loves a bit of
depressiveness yeah I'm like Doom and
Gloom it's all [__] have it confirmed
fabulous but no thank you so much for
coming it was an absolutely brilliant
interview if people want to find out
about your amazing work online what is
the best way to do that how can they
join
um the struggle yes well this is the
good part that we're doing something
about it so um bigbrotherwatch.org dot
UK we're on Twitter as well at Big
Brother watch uh we're on YouTube it
would rather watch HQ
um and this particular campaign page is
at
minitruth.co.uk intro orwellian style
and silky keep up the good work because
you are is very important in this
investigation you've done by the time
this goes out he hope for I I'm hopeful
it's exploded everywhere you've got us
it's coming out in the mail on Sunday
and you've got a bunch of interviews
coming up and I hope this contributes to
it so thanks for coming back on what
you're doing and thank you guys for
watching and listening if you want to
see a couple of bonus questions they uh
our supporters have already submitted
and hear the answers to them join our
locals we will see you there
and for those of you who like your
trigonometry on the go always remember
that it's available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
people in Tech myself included tend to
always make the false assumption that
all progress will only be used for good
do you think politicians have the
necessary grasp of technology I mean we
know the answer to that and it's
potential negative implications for
privacy or are they too often blinded by
positivity from tech companies
foreign
[Music]